ازمه نفسيه جماعيه تعانيها المنطقه باسرها
والسبب الزلزال المدمر وتركيا تبدا باحصاء
الخسائر الماديه ومحاسبه المسؤولين وهبوط
ارضي في مصر يثير رعب المواطنين ووزاره
الري تطمن الناس ما له علاقه بالزلزال
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من اسبوع مثل اليوم كان العالم على موعد
مع كارثه طبيعيه ما كان احد متحضر لها ولا
يمكن اصلا الواحد يكون جاهز لشيء مثل
نتكلم طبعا عن زلزال تركيا وسوريا عدد
القتلى تجاوز 37 الف قتيل ومئات الالاف من
الجرحى والحصيله بتزيد يوم بعد يوم والامم
المتحده بتتوقع موحه زياده عاديه بل
بتتوقع تضاعف عدد الضحايا ومع انه من يوم
الخميس والكل بيقول خلاص فرص العثور على
ناجين تقريبا بتختفي لكن عكس التوقعات
والطبيعه والعلم ووفق اراده رب العالمين
وبس في ناس لسه بتطلع عايشه من تحت
الانقاض رغم انهم بدون اكل او شرب اوكسجين
او درجات او درجات الحراره لازم نذكر انها
صفر او تحت الصفر مسنين واطفال وشباب لسه
بيطلعوا عايشين
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
ضحايا زلزال سوريا وتركيا ما بنبالغ لو
قلنا انهم بالملايين فغير القتلى والجرحى
بنقدر نقول بكل واقعيه انه في ازمه نفسيه
جماعيه سببها الزلزال في الاف الناجين
اللي لحظات الزلزال اثرت في نفسياتهم هدول
اللي نجوا في لحظتها تخيلوا عادل يقعدوا
ساعات او ايام تحت الانقاض قديش حجم الضغط
النفسي اللي تعرضوا له في كمان الازمه
النفسيه اللي بيعانيها الناس اللي الان
خسروا اهل وقرايب وجيران واصحاب في هذا
الزلزال المدمر وفي كمان فرق الانقاذ
واللي شافوه والازمه اللي ممكن يعانوا
منها الان ومع فارق حجم الماساه طبعا لكن
غير كل هذولي في الناس اللي في دول ثانيه
وبعيده وجلسه بتتابع الاخبار المؤلمه
والمؤثره هذه وهذول كمان تاثرت نفسياتهم
بما حدث يعني صراحه من فداحه الحدث يعني
خلينا نحكي عن هذا الموضوع مع صديقنا
الطبيب النفسي دكتور ليث العبادي اهلا فيك
معنا دكتور ليث يعني ناس تتكلم عن انه
تروما جماعيه او صدمه جماعيه هل نقدر فعلا
نقول انه في شيء مشترك صدمه مشتركه ممكن
تجمع كل الناس اللي عاصروا هذا الحدث
الاستضافه وهو حدث حزين
والصدمه على جميع حتى اللي بيشاهدوا في
التلفاز واحنا عن بعد مصابين بصدمه بشبهوا
وقوه الزلزال بقنابل ذريه وانا بشبهه
بمجموعه قنابل نفسيه انفجرت في كل العالم
اللي ذكرتيها الان عن انواع مختلفه من
انواع الصدمات هاي كلها اجت مع بعضها يعني
الصدمه الجسديه والاذى الجسدي اللي اصاب
المصابي غير عن فقدان اشخاص اخرين غير عن
فقدان المنزل غير عن تغيير في في كل
الامور غير عن الطقس والبرد يعني مجموعه
ضغوطات نفسيه كبيره بمر عليها فيها العالم
كله بدرجات متفاوته اكثر ناس طبعا اللي هم
اللي تاثروا بشكل مباشر في هذا الزلزال هل
في اسم نفسي للصدمه الجماعيه مثلا هذه
اللي بيعيشوها
او العلميه يعني
كوارث طبيعيه والاضطرابات النفسيه مع بعض
الفوارث الطبيعيه
نفس الاشياء اللي بتيجي للناس مثلا بعد
الحروب
ما بعد الصدمه وهو تقريبا شيء مشابه بمر
للشخص بحاله مختلطه من الحزن والقلق
والتوتر واليقظه كانه لحظه الصدمه تستمر
معه وتعود له على شكل ذكريات بعد المرور
بوقت صعب جدا الذكريات فجاه بتجي مباشر
مباغته بدون انت ما تختار فيها اي خيار
والله يعين كل من هو مصاب فيها من خيالات
من ذكريات تعاد نفس لحظه وقوع الحادث
مرارا وتكرارا وبالعاده يحاول الشخص انه
يخفف عن نفسه بالتجنب ولكن اللي واقع تحت
المشكله والمصيبه سيكون صعب عليه تجنب وقد
يكون عامل مساعد يعني ان شاء الله طيب
الدكتور ليث لما نجي نحن بنت في هذا
الموضوع الان ويعني فعليا انت ذكرت يعني
خساره حياه خساره منزل خساره تفاصيل كثيره
يعني الواحد يعجز عن وصفه يعني هل هذا
الموضوع لما نتكلم عنه الان في وسط ما
الامور هذه جلسه بتصير رفاهيه يمكن لازم
ناجلها لبعدين
امل النفسي مهم جدا جدا جدا حتى على
العامل الجسدي يعني
العلاج في جزء من الحزن والانكار يعني في
ناس صابوا خدش من الانهيار من المصابين
يجب ان يتلقى الرعايه والدعم الطبي النفسي
باسرع وقت في بعض الناس اذا دخل في نوبه
كلياتنا ساره تحت الضغط نستجيب بشكل مختلف
في البعض بيحزن شوي بتوتر شوي ولكن في
البعض ممكن يدخل بنوبات من الطلبات نفسيه
شديده اذا تركت ان تعالج بعدين ممكن تخلف
اثر لا لا نستطيع علاجه بالاضطرابات
النفسيه بشكل عام كلما طالت مده النوبه
انما صعد وصعب علاجه اوكي فانت بتقول انه
لابد من الان انه التعامل مع هذا الموضوع
واضافه العلاج النفسي كما العلاج الجسدي
يعني
ومعالجين ومسعفين النفسيين بنفس اهميه وقد
يكون اهم في بعض الحالات حذف شده الحاله
دكتور ليث يمكن واحده من الاشياء طبعا
يعني البارقه العمل اللي شفناها في هذه
الازمه خروج ناس احياء من تحت الانقاب في
مجناس احياء من تحت الانقاب في منهم حتى
اطفال في منهم رضع الاطفال تحديدا والرضع
هدول لاي درجه حيتذكروا تحديدا هذا اللي
صار وقديش ممكن يكون يؤثر على مستقبلهم
يؤثر بسبب التغيير اللي خلفه بغض النظر عن
العمر ولكن الذكرى كذكره وصدمه ما يعني
بتكون اقل في الاعمار ما اقل من ست سنوات
بقفل 6 سنوات بتكون امور اوضح ولكن التغير
المفاجئ اللي ممكن يصير في نظام الحياه
الاطفال متعودين على الروتين معين والنظام
وجدول ثابت من الساعات استيقاظ ساعات نوم
اشكال وجوه ناس هاي الاشياء تغيرها وفقدان
الاهل ومقدمين رعايه في عمر حتى سنتين الى
ثلاث سنوات بشكل دور كبير على تشكيل
شخصيته في المستقبل فالاطفال الرضع حتى
وبس بشكل اكبر من بعد السنه لعمر ثلاث
سنوات حتى في هذا العمر قد يؤثر عليهم
سلبا بشكل كبير اذا ما تم تعويضهم يعني رح
يكون صعب التعويض بشكل كامل ولكن قدر
الامكان العوده الى نظام الحياه السابق
على الاقل من ساعات نوم ساعات
استيقاظ ووجبات اكل ورعايه ودفع كمان
دكتور الليث يعني يمكن كمان الان لانه
وسائل الاعلام كلها تطورت وصارت الناس
بتقابلهم اول ما بيطلعوا بياخدوا منهم
حوارات وفيديوهات هدول الاطفال لاحقا يعني
عندهم حتى فيديوهات بتوثق هذه اللحظه
المريعه اللي عاشوها قديش تعتقد انه
يعني مش صحي للاطفال مقابلتهم في هذا
الوقت ولا يعني كيف نقدر نسميه يعني في
نهايه اليوم شغله الصحفي اكيد انه يلتقط
الخبر والحدث في هذه اللحظه وفي هذه
اللحظه يوثق حدث انه في شخص طلع عايش من
تحت الانقاض واكيد لكن ماذا عن هذا الشخص
ندور الاعلام الايجابي بتسليط الضوء على
مصائب الاخرين ودفع الناس انها تتبرع
وتساعد وتقوم بفعل عن جد ممكن يفرق ولكن
بنفس الوقت يجب ان يكون حذرين بالاثر
النفسي على المشاهدين وعلى الاشخاص نفسهم
مستقبلا توثيق لحظات معينه والام معينه
يسبب اضطرابات نفسيه في المشاهدين يعني
جزء كبير من مراجعين في العياده في بعض
اللقطات ادت الى بعض الانتكاسات وبعض انت
سوء الحاله النفسيه احنا لابد من شحن
بالتحديد الطفل اللي كان يبحث عن كذا يعني
في قصص معينه بحد ذاتها اثرت سلبا نفسيا
هسه انك تجذب التعاطف الجمعي شيء له فوائد
ولكن عند بعض الحالات قد يسبب ويؤدي الى
اثر سلبي جدا وبرضو حتى توثيق الكثير من
لحظات اللي فيها خطوطيه والتي قد نتعدى
يعني في اعتقد في كود اخلاقي او او مرجع
اخلاقي للصحفيين بشكل عام يعني بنصح كل
اخواننا الصحفيين
انسانيه في هذه اللحظه والحقيقه يعني كل
زملائنا اللي على الارض يعني هم بيتعاملوا
مع الحدث مش بس كصحفيين هم في النهايه
بيتعاملوا معه كانسان ويعني واضح جدا
تاثرهم في هذيك اللحظات وسعادتهم بانه
مثلا شخص نجا في هذا الموقف وهذا الشيء
وكل التحيه صراحه لكل الطواقم الاعلاميه
اللي جالسه بتغطي وبتنقل يعني الحقيقه بس
خليني ارجع ايضا لموضوع
الناجين تحديدا يعني
للاسف شفنا اسر بكاملها
راحت ومثلا بقي شخص او طفل او ما الى ذلك
حتى في انتشرت صوره لشخص بيقول انه توفت
كل اسرته فكان بيقول كلهم بخير الا انا
هل فعلا ممكن الشخص يشعر
بانه بالذنب او الندم ان هو بيجي عايش
صدمه بشكل
اشهرها واشهر تصنيف اللي هو الانكار الغضب
المساومه الاكتئاب قبل للوصول للقبول وكل
هالمراحل وخصوصا الحزن يرتبط كثيرا بشعور
الندم والشعور بالذنب الخارج عن الفعل
اللي قام فيه الشخص بشكل عام نحن نشعر في
الذنب عندما نقوم بسلوك يتخالف او يختلف
مع معتقداتنا الداخليه الاساسيه ولكن بعد
الصدمه شعور الاكتئاب والحزن الشديد قد
يؤدي انه انا قصرت ماذا لو ماذا لو انا
غيرت بصير يبني تصرفاته ويحاسب نفسه على
سلوك
في هذه اللحظه انا ما كنت موجود او كذا او
ايش سبب نجاتي انا تحديدا
وبصير يحاسب نفسه على بعض السلوكيات كانه
يعلم بحدوث الزلزال ولكن بذكر
كل انت لم تكن تعلم بحدوث الزلزال ما قبل
فما كان في شيء كنت ستغيره لانك لا تعلم
الكثير بحكي لو اني غيرت لو اني اخذت ابني
لو اني طلعته كل شخص نجا باللحظات
الكارثيه السريعه كل شخص الوعي يخف ويصير
في زي رده فعل للنجاه بصير في جزء اماكن
اخرى في الدماغ تعمل لكي تنجو بنفسك فحتى
القدره على الحكم ما بتكون بالوضع الحالي
يعني الانسان بيتصرف كده خلاص بغريزته
يعني ما بيفكر في هذيك اللحظه يعني
طيب صراحه موضوع يعني ثقيل عن النفس صراحه
بس كان مهم انه نفتحه معك
وحضرتك كمان قلت انه يعني كثير من
المراجعينك برضو ذكروا هذا الموضوع لما
نراجعوك تاثير موضوع الزلزال واحنا طبعا
هنا في غرفه الاخبار ما عندنا حديث برضو
الا مدى فداحه هذا الموضوع ونوضع عالمي
يعني الكل متاثر طبعا والاخص طبعا اللي
عايشين في وسط الحدث الله يعينهم نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا صديقنا
الطبيب النفسي دكتور ليث العبادي شكرا لك
وبعد مرور اسبوع على الزلزال واقتراب
عمليات الانقاذ والانتشال من نهايتها بدا
الان الكلام يكثر عن الخسائر الماديه
السوريه الى الان ما في اي شيء واضح او
رسمي لا عدد المباني المدمره ولا تقديرات
الحجم الخسائر الماديه ولا شيء اما تركيا
فبداوا في احصاء الخسائر امس مع اعتقال او
سمعنا اخبار عن اعتقال عدد من المتعهدين
المسؤولين عن بناء عمارات ومجمعات من
الانهارت بالكامل وفي تحقيقات وملاحقات
لمتعهدين اخرين بتهمه الاهمال والبناء
بطرق مخالفه ومن ساعات اعلن القبض على
مالك شركه مسؤوله عن بناء عدد من المباني
في اضنه هيئه الكوارث التركيه بتقول او
بتقدر انه عدد المباني اللي دمرت بالكامل
6444 مبنى والاتحاد الشركات والاعمال في
تركيا بتوقع ارتفاع عجز الموازنه من 3.5
الى 5.4 بسبب في الميه طبعا بسبب جهود
اعاده الاعمار بتقول انه خسائر تركيا
مليار دولار وهذا يشكل 10% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للبلد اما تكلفه اعاده
الاعمار فيقدر بانها راح تستهلك
5.5% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ورغم
تاكيدات اردوغان من كم يوم انه حيرجعوا
يعمروا البلد خلال سنه لكن خبراء بيقولوا
انه هذا صعب كثير وانه الموضوع راح ياخذ
سنوات على الاغلب
والتزامن مع الزلزال اللي شاغل الدنيا
كلها والتوقعات الماليه المنصات الاخبار
عن زلازل القادمه كمان في صور متداوله في
مصر عامله حالها كبيره من الرعب والقلق
والخوف وهي الصور اللي شايفينها امامكم
مشاهدينا لهذا الهبوط الارضي بمنطقه
السلوم على كورنيش الاسكندريه بعمق عده
امتار وطول عشرات الامتار
الناس بس شافت منظر هبوط الارض خافت
وانرعبت وكثار منهم فورا ربطوا الموضوع
بالزلزال اللي فات وتوقعات الزلازل اللي
جايه وقالوا هذا يا اما من توابع زلزال
سوريا وتركيا يا اما صاير زلزال في مصر او
في زلزال جاي وهذا انذار وتحضير وخاصه
وانه هذا مو اول انهيار ومن اسبوع بالضبط
وفي نفس يوم زلزال سوريا وتركيا الكبير
كلش الاسكندريه كان واوصار في تشققات
طوليه صوروها الناس ونشروا مقاطع منها
كمان وهذه امتدت عشرين كيلو متر والناس
وقتها قالوا برضو هادي من الهزات
الارتداديه تشقق الاسبوع الماضي مع انهيار
اليوم خلي الخوف والرعب يسيطر على منصات
مصر
وزاره الري والموارد المائيه ردت على خوف
الناس وحبت تطمنهم واكدت بكل الطرق
والوسائل انه الموضوع له زلزال ولا له
علاقه بالزلازل لكن تفسيرات الوزاره تعددت
يعني في بيان صحفي للوزاره قال انه سبب
الهبوط الارضي هو الامواج العاتيه
المصاحبه لنوه الكرم وانه تم اصلاح الهبوط
والتعامل مع نوه الكرم هي ظاهره مناخيه
ترتبط بشده الرياح ووزاره الامطار وبتكون
خلال مده زمنيه محدده اذا كان بيان
الوزاره لكن المتحدث باسم الوزاره كان
تفسيره مختلف وعبر برنامج الحكايه مع
الزميل عمرو اديب قال انه السبب هو تدفق
مياه الامطار وما له اي علاقه بالامواج
والموضوع يعني طبقا لمعاينه اللجنه ناتج
عن وجود كميات كبيره من الامطار في
المنطقه الامطار دي تتفقد بشكل كبير
واثارت على البلاطات بتاعه الكورنيش في
المنطقه دي اللي ظهرت
يعني حضرتك في الصور ده تاثير ناتج عن
تدفق كميات كبيره من مياه الامطار يعني
الموضوع ما لوش علاقه
بالامواج او المنطقه الشاطئيه في حد ذاتها
او تاثير الامواج في المنطقه دي ولكن
التاثير في معظمه ناتج عن تدفق كميات
كبيره من الامطار على المنطقه دي
عموما سواء الموضوع من الامواج او من
الامطار او من الهواء في ناس كثير اطمنت
ان المهم الموضوع مو زلزال ولا له علاقه
فيه بس ترى لكن للامانه في ناس تانيه مو
مصدقه ولسه بتشكك
تبعات زلزال تركيا وصلت كمان الى كمبوديا
وبمو المقصود هنا هزات ارتداديه او شيء من
هذا النوع بل المقصود ممكن نسميه التوتر
سياسي او اعلامي فرئيس وزراء كمبوديا امر
باغلاق محطه اذاعيه اسمها فويس اوف
ديمقراصي او صوت الديمقراطيه واتهمهم
بالافتراء على ابنه اللي هو بالمناسبه
كمان جنرال وبقود الجيش والحزب الحاكم
مرشحه عشان يخلف والده لما يتنحى وانتشرت
صوت او انتشرت كمان صور كمان من اغلاق
المحطه الاذاعيه اللي لها كمان موقع
اخباري وصور للموظفين وهم جالسين بيبكوا
في المقر
كلكم بتسالوا الان اكيد ايش علاقه الزلزال
تركيا في الموضوع هذا العلاقه هي ان
الاذاعه نقلت خبر انه رئيس الجيش اللي هو
ابن رئيس الحكومه وقع نيابه عن والده
وثيقه تسمح بالتبرع ب 100 الف دولار
للمساعده في الاغاثه من الزلزال لكن رئيس
الوزراء الكنبودي طلع وقال كذب وما حصل
وهو الوحيد كرئيس الوزراء عنده السلطه
للتوقيع على وثيقه من هذا النوع ومع انه
الاذاعه والموقع طلعوا اعترفوا انه
ارتكبوا خطا لكن هذا ما ارض رئيس الحكومه
لمعروف بقبضه الحديديه في الحكم من 38 سنه
وبالمناسبه هذه الاذاعه كانت واحده يعني
من اخر وسائل الاعلام الحره يعني في
البلاد
رغم السعاده انه تم انقاذها لكن المقطع
الجاي اللي طفله سوريه بتروي اللي صار
معها
الله اكبر
اجى
الحمد والشادي
[موسيقى]
من الدكتور
في طفل تركي كمان بكى كثار الساعات
الماضيه بعد ما سمعوا في مقطع فيديو اول
طلب طلبوا من فرق الانقاذ لما نطلعوه من
تحت الانقاض بعد 170 ساعه
وصلنا لختم حلقتنا مشاهدينا نعود والخاكم
غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]